Mình sẽ bình nhân dân như thế nào, cái tư thế nào.
Vì xuống lấy sống thế nào.
Để lại để tôi nào, mình chỉ có tôi nào cần phải.
Vậy, dài qua, tôi nào cần phải cũng cấp nó sức tế phần.
Các bạn có văn phòng bán chỉ đạo phòng thủ rất sức bú ra.
Thúng cái sơ bổ tình đến sang này.
Là có chính là thế mà, năm người mất thích, giòn người lũ tại miền trong.
Vất liệu tại cuộc họp.
Tụ tưởng phòng mình chính là lâu gió.
Lấy là nó tụi lũ đặc miệt lưỡng tại miền trong.
Như lời có lựng lưỡng tụi lựng có.
Tụ tưởng gifu, là có mặt công liện chỉ đạo.
Già phó tụ tưởng cho nông hà chủ chỉ họp với các mộ này để phương.
Và đang chực tiếp đi kiểm tra chỉ đạo uống phó viên mưu.
Tại các tính miền trong.
Tụ tưởng chỉ đạo, các liền phương kiếp thời tham họt,
lộn viên hỗ trợ các gia đình, không người thích mà.
Mất liệt, tập trung cứu trở người bị thương.
Và thực hiện nay các chính xác khổ trợ tâm nhất, lựa vuy nhiên dân bùng kia tay.
Tụ tưởng yêu cầu, phải làm kim quét làm chất lệ,
vực dây giờ lại xưa tả nử dân ra khỏe của vực nguy hiệm.
Mauda mừng tập tập phòng nếu yêu phòng nước hoặc, nước quón nước sạch và tốt khở trung.
Tụ tưởng nếu gió, gà liệu phương nếu cần phải hỗ trợ gạch,
lương tập lương khô, tìt lệ sốt.
Trương mắt, chúng hỗ trợ này hai tưởng nếu không cho thành cụ hối.
Còn khôn năm trên kháng này về phức chuyển, tự nử dân.
Lựa gần cộng độ con hoàn, khẩn trên tiếp tế trong nử dân.
Tại những khu vực miệng nập sau, chia cắt,
và hơi động thay phương tiệm lệ hỗ trợ như dân,
dịch quát không để ai biết nói, dịch, mất khác.
Tụ tưởng nếu bố tài chính là cũng không này hơi là một chăm năm tìm.
Còn gì có, gà em, gà em chỉ là tỏa quân.
Còn này còn truyền là một tâm tìm.
Lâm này kì về đây.
Tụ tưởng yêu cầu bộ công thương, bộ quát và công nghệ,
chỉ đã bắt tập đoàn cình trên khá phục gấp liệt,
sau viên thông trả lại trong thời gian sấm nhất,
lình người rất nắm được tông tìm đầy đủ kìa thời.
Cái địa phương bộ ngành, không phương ánh khá phục cầu quát,
không phục các khoản đậu ngài sau khi nước rúc.
Những là trường học mà các cơ sởi đế,
giá sản lực lượng phương tiệm, bật từ vô trợ về sĩ được giá,
sử lý môi trường, phòng chống dịch bệnh xấu lối.
Tụ tưởng chỉ đạo các cơ quan trinh năng,
trù lộ phương ở về thống nước nàn, tổ chức tiếng rộng,
để chiến cái ai thực hiện sớm cắt chi sẽ có trợ về thвế,
tiếng rộng mởi nhập.
Để người dân ra nghiệp bị tài, sớm phục hồi,
khó phục sạch xuất tì rời.
Tụ tưởng phòng chí yêu cầu, cắp mốc nành,
tại trù lộng sử lý này kính ý của các địa phương,
về nụ cầu cấp mắt theo thật quyền,
vô tầm quyền thì bao cáo tụ tưởng chi phụ.
Chúng đỏ có việc sử lý này cắt kính ý,
tưởng hợp bảo gó phê tình như thế thài.
Rồi thiền đây, hồi tụ tưởng chi phụ chức mấy bố dơ hàng này,
để văn phòng chi phụ tưởng hợp thăm yêu đàn người chi phụ.
Gó bảo gó cắt có tưởng quyền chỉ sát kì thời.